[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a segment where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show yeah okay so
far hundreds of challengers not one
winner right no one's ever caught us
making a mistake because we don't make
them we do not make them exactly you
just said what I said a little slower
well right night-night
a fan named Randy bullet says he thinks
he caught a mistake he says it happened
when I was talking to actress melissa
rauch hi last week I was watching and
you were interviewing melissa rauch from
Big Bang Theory near the end of your
interview you told her that your stage
15 film so close to her stage 25 at
Warner Brothers Studios in Burbank that
sometimes you've actually taken a tennis
ball and struck her studio from your
studio you filmed literally I could hit
it with a tennis ball right now and I
often do well I took a look on Google
Maps and I pretty much figured out it's
about 275 feet from yours to hers and
unfortunately stage 20 is directly
between I'm not a math genius I'm not a
physics professor but I do know that a
fuzzy two-ounce tennis ball it's pretty
hard to throw that far so what I'm
trying to say is
that guy has way too much time on it
yeah yeah it really does
well I'm sorry Randy but you are dead
wrong you didn't take into account how
amazingly far I can throw a tennis ball
I could easily easily throw this tennis
ball from my stage to stage 25 I'm going
to prove it to all of you right now
okay here's the deal this is my stage
right here stage 15 that's where I tape
this right next door is stage 20 and
right over that stage on the other side
stage 25 where they shoot big bang let's
do this
[Applause]
[Applause]
the challenge the challenge still stands
if you think you've supported an air app
on our show reported at team coca calm /
ha hi friend an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make it shut
me out of the maestro with him / hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please